esally because I just think as a society
we always talk about how men are awkward
but I think women were just as awkward
we just get away with it because you
know we're like pretty and stuff so the
guys guys don't even care if you're
awkward but okay so women filter out men
below six foot that is the most common
pick on the dating apps is they just so
if I was a dude I would lie I would lie
on dating apps I would absolutely lie
because the thing is he is right women
will date shorter but it the shorter
guys kind of have to have something to
make up for it but the issue with
tradcons is I just think a lot of
tradcons are are a bit oblivious to just
how picky women are